I can't type it better than decorating
we just she and brill black day
you leave home in the morning and you think of it
we are going today 1
cover some nice topics in the city council
because the city council was and is in the 1
I have by the way
this afternoon the city council behind closed doors
with the
summarizing facts in De Wijk was informed
and you think of it
well today we are going to make 1 few nice decisions
take 1 few inches to the city again
to move forward
and then you become
startled by
I get angry about it and sad
and I can feel it all over my body and my toes
you can no longer concentrate
the councilors who saw it to me
actually have no attention at all for the council
from now on or 2: 30 am
is constantly on your phone
that is natural
no use
that you answer the phone during the city council
but you do
when the cops call you and it kept happening
yes you don't expect something like that on such a day
and I think many with me now say the question
ask them the question of why
what is actually behind this
but I have every confidence in that
police and justice
going to figure that out
and then we will do that at some point in the near future
do tell
but yes I am now mainly plagued by
feelings of sadness and anger